a gambler 114 million dollars on last
night's World Series game yeah here's
what suspicious turns out it was some
guy named Yu Darvish
[Applause]
yeah president Trump tweeted
congratulations to the Houston Astros
for winning the World Series yep
Trump said he's so happy for the Astros
he's only going to deport some of their
play this his promise that's his promise
yeah yeah he said just the infielders
that's it so you know politics the
Republican tax plan came out today yeah
and President Trump announced it will
bring trillions of dollars to the u.s.
trillions of dollars yeah he then said
specifically to three members of my
cabinet it's gonna come yeah because
they don't have enough
okay this guy was supposed to rub my
nipple and then he gave you a little
pinch but gave it a little pinch there
it in yeah yeah
right here right here yeah you guys he's
kind of a creep isn't he yeah you never
know what that guy is gonna pull yeah
what's going on
today President Trump tweeted that our
criminal justice system is a joke yeah
he then tweeted I mean how is my entire
family not in prison
that's good good he listens if you tell
him what he likes he listens that's nice
it's got creepy fast Amazon in the news
Amazon has and has unveiled unveiled a
new way to view its products in 3d yeah
Amazon's calling their new invention a
store
Virgen CEO Richard Branson is launching
a cruise line that is adults only
yeah after hearing about it Kevin Spacey
said not interested
that that joke reaction was like a log
flume wasn't it
splash else is going on in an interview
jeopardy host Alex Trebek revealed that
he once tripped hard on hash brownies
tripped hard on hash brownies yeah
probably Trebek spent hours saying what
is my hand for 800
you